- [Narrator] Fondue.
It's this thing we do with cheese.
We melt it.
We dip it.
We eat it.
In the '70s, it became super popular.
But that didn't just happen by chance.
There was an ominous force behind it,
a real-life cheese cartel.
(dramatic music)
100 years ago, cheese was a
hot commodity in Switzerland.
It was exported at high volumes
and played a major role
in the Swiss economy.
But that all changed after World War I.
European countries, devastated by the war,
could no longer afford to buy
expensive, imported cheese,
which was bad news for Switzerland.
So the government stepped in,
and they formed The Cheese Union.
Basically, it was a cartel,
and it worked like this.
The first thing they did
was force every dairy
farmer and cheesemonger
to fix the price of cheese,
eliminating competition,
meaning everyone could stay in the game.
The cheese cartel also told them
exactly how much cheese to
make and limited the varieties.
So instead of making thousands
of different kinds of cheese,
they only made seven.
And it worked.
The cartel controlled the
cheese supply for decades.
By the '70s, they got greedy
and wanted to expand their
cheese racket globally.
So they introduced the world to a dish
already popular in the
freezing cold Alps, fondue.
By marketing cheese for fondue,
the cartel was able to sell more.
I mean, think about it.
It takes a lot, and I
mean a lot, of cheese
to fill a pot.
But, as with most
cartels, things got shady.
Money went missing.
People went to jail.
And by the 1990s, the Swiss
Cheese Union was dismantled.
So, there you have it.
The reason we know and love fondue
is because of a shady government program
that convinced the world
to consume massive amounts
of melted cheese.